so dj the infinite gamer had left a
comment where he had basically pointed
out that he felt like all this
multiversal madness would kind of lead
into or at least has something to do
with kang
and that's something that i've been
wondering about recently right with this
whole thing but before we get into that
we do need to thank our sponsor for this
video atlas vpn so for those of you guys
who do not know right now at this moment
and this is an absolutely insane deal
atlas vpn is running this massive
discount right it means you can get like
a three-year subscription for just a
buck 99 a month for two bucks a month
and they've got like a 30-day money-back
guarantee it's insane
you don't need to know much about vpns
to know that's an insane deal so for
those of you guys who don't know what a
vpn is this means virtual private
network and what it means is that when
you have atlas vpn activated on your
devices your laptop or your desktop or
your phone your internet traffic is
funneled through essentially an
encrypted tunnel meaning no one can
really see what you're actually doing so
it can protect you from like spying
public wi-fi issues and it hides your ip
address and your online activities now
one of the huge benefits of having a vpn
is the issue of geo-restriction for
those of you guys who don't know what
that means sometimes streaming services
will have programming set up which is
only available in certain regions so if
you're in the united states you may not
be able to see programming that's
actually available on netflix in canada
but with atlasvpn you can actually
bypass all of that which basically means
that you can see content on streaming
services that is not readily available
to you so again right now at this moment
atlas vpn is running this massive
discount right it means you can get like
a three year subscription for two bucks
a month with a 30 day money back
guarantee so time's running out make
sure you get your deal by clicking the
link in the video description below and
with that being said let's get back into
our video but yeah so here's what i've
been wondering
how does kane the conqueror tie into
this because i know that at the end of
the the whole 10-year arc right the
infinity saga that feigning them came
out and they said we're not doing any
more 10-year arcs right we're not doing
that anymore instead it's just going to
be three to five-year arcs that are
going to be small and self-contained
but i'm really hoping that like this all
kind of leads into king and maybe it's
just coming out of the the last 10 years
that i can't really see the mcu doing it
any other way that like in at the end of
the first avengers movie we got like the
teaser for thanos and then it was just
small little things over the course of
the remaining films that led into like
the infinity gauntlet and all that kind
of stuff and each one of the teasers
became more and more significant until
it was basically like yeah man uh so the
whole thing with with like you know
infinity war and avengers in game is all
basically just the infinity gauntlet uh
with a couple other things thrown in and
that's basically it right uh maybe it's
just me kind of coming out of that that
10-year period
and expecting that that i look at this
idea of kane the conqueror and it's kind
of like okay how does all this tie in
because here's the thing when you look
at these characters and again we're kind
of borrowing from comics here but when
you look at these characters and even
just looking at them in the mcu the
build-up to thanos was immense by the
build of the thanos was amazing and it
was one of those things where when we
got the post-credits scene at the end of
avengers right and like you know it's
kind of like you know to to fight them
mr court death and then thanos turns
around and smiles it's like josh the old
thanos mistress death all that kind of
stuff and while we didn't necessarily
get mistress death in the traditional
sense the way that we wanted to although
looking at that post-credits scene it
looks like the early idea was to go in
that direction and then ultimately they
just kind of changed it up made it a
little more grounded for the mcu as
opposed to thanos walking around with
some chick who just smoked cigarettes
all day listening to the cure crying
about how hard the world is and how
she's just so misunderstood by the world
you know that kind of thing um so they
ended up going with the direction of
like the infinity gauntlet and all that
but the build-up to like infinity war in
avengers inn game was big and even when
they did what was it the whole was it
the phase three announcement that you
guys remember that video they came out
when they announced like black panther
and all that stuff and everybody went
nuts uh where foggy was talking about
how like everything that they were doing
had led to that point uh where he was
like you know every everything since
like the first avengers movie has led to
this which according to the recent
interviews was a bunch of malarkey
apparently they have no plan
they're just making movies with marvel
characters and that's basically it which
if that's true that would kind of
explain what's going on with king
because we're not getting the same kind
of build up with kang that we got with
thanos and what's so ironic here is kang
is a far more legitimate threat than
thanos is thanos is just a guy who is a
nihilist believes life is meaningless
he's down bad for mistress death and is
always doing everything he can to try to
like court her favor right as some
people call him the ultimate simp
i don't know if i agree with that term
but nonetheless thanos has like he has a
pretty simple motivations there's not
really a whole lot to him and while kang
has some relatively simple simple
motivations too
anybody out there who is familiar with
comics will tell you a guy who can
travel back and forth through the time
stream is a far more credible threat
than a guy that can assemble some magic
rocks on a glove and blink out half the
life in the universe that that king is a
far bigger threat than thanos is because
at any point in time unless thanos is in
possession of the mind stone at any
point in time king can go back in time
and just stop thanos from being born or
he can just capture the infinity
gauntlets at the beginning of everything
right when like nemesis first created
them if you go that route or where like
they were they first came into existence
snatch them all up take them to the
future and nobody can ever use them
again i mean it's just it's there's a
variety of ways in which kane can just
totally distort the time stream by just
moving back and forth through time not
only that looking at what he has in the
future all that technology that super
advanced armor i mean kang is really
really powerful there's a lot more to
him than a guy who can manipulate time
and so i feel like
there should be a lot more build up to
king than what we're getting right now
that it's just kind of like hey guys so
we're at the end of loki um
basically sylvie killed he who remains
or nathaniel whatever you want to call
him uh killed him and now like kang is
the one who created the tva and is
running the show and uh
we'll see you in quantum mania and it's
just kind of like no i mean come on like
we should have more build up for kane to
conquer than what we're seeing right now
this guy should be appearing in
post-credits scenes now looking at
what's going on in doctor strange too
looking at like the illuminati universe
is what it seems to be there's a lot of
a lot of theories because i kind of
broke down
that i did some google searching this
morning and uh and i kind of feel bad
because i feel like now my ideas are at
least aren't original to me even if like
they're not original at all like
you know now they're not original to me
but one of the one of the plot leaks
that came out is that the multiversal
illuminati basically stem from like the
illuminati universe right where in a lot
of ways it looks like the great society
from like the incursions right what is
it earth four two nine a bunch of zeros
and then a one somewhere in there those
those in some capacity those numbers are
arranged in such a way to where it
represents that universe
i get a little fuzzy on the numerical
designations for universes uh but it
looks very similar to the great society
for those guys who don't know what that
is basically during the cree scroll war
the traditional superheroes who were
called the archetypes of justice were
basically killed they failed in trying
to repel the pre-scroll war and instead
what you got was the great society
which was basically the justice league
uh and they in turn went forward and
saved everything and then just kind of
became the superheroes of that world and
while i wouldn't say the illuminati like
represent the justice league in the mcu
what i mean to say is that it's kind of
like this perfect world so to speak
right we're like i don't know if it'd be
considered a utopia but like they came
out on top and they've quelled all the
major threats and all that kind of stuff
so you get like the iron legion by
hopefully tom cruise iron man and so on
and so forth um and supposedly that's
the world where wanda visits herself and
like where her kids are in the trailer
it's in that world uh and that
apparently wanda ends up seizing control
of herself again these are leaks rumors
i don't know how much of this stuff is
actually true and we won't know until
the movie comes out uh but the thing
about this is i feel like sure that kind
of stuff is cool but that's a great
chance to show like some involvement
with kang i know a lot of people are
speculating that the the whole fight
scene that takes place between wanda and
uh a person who looks like captain
marvel a lot of people are saying like
they hope that it's basically iron lad
that it's a version of kang before he
becomes king which is actually what
happened in the comics that kang visited
his younger self and told him like
you're destined to become me and his
younger self was like but i don't want
to so he became a hero and called sort
of calling himself iron lad that's
essentially how that character exists
right iron lad explained in five seconds
uh so that's basically it a lot of
people are hoping that's the case and i
have to believe that beyond the fact
that it just seems cool that hope stems
from the fact that like we have so
little exposure to king the conqueror in
the mcu right it's just he is a guy who
conquered the multiverse at some point
or at least was part of a giant war that
broke out and now he seemingly rules it
and we have no idea what he's doing
right we have no no clue what's going on
so i feel like what's going on in the
mcu right now assuming that doctor
strange doesn't give us anything are
just some hugely missed opportunities to
show us what kang is doing and to give
us this idea of just how credible of a
threat king is how dangerous this guy is
because what i really don't want to see
here what i'm really hoping does not
happen here is that the only inference
we got to the nature of kang was in the
loki tv show and that he who remains
died and the sacred timeline merged with
the rest of the multiverse and now kang
basically is ruling everything by
himself right or at least is sitting at
the end of time right so it might as
well be ruling it i mean we saw how he
who remains manipulated the sacred
timeline by getting rid of people who
deviated from their quote unquote uh
path basically um what i'm really hoping
is that's not the only reference we get
then he shows up in quantum mania he
fights like ant-man and company for a
little while they win and then that's it
i'm really hoping that's not the case
because here's the thing kang is a guy
where you could have him as an
overarching villain for quite some time
and if that really is the case i think
that speaks largely to one of the
biggest issues of the mcu and i've
talked about this before and i don't
mind talking about it again they always
get rid of the best villains but king is
a villain that you could have for like
like a series of phases right for like
phase one two three four five you know
for whichever ones come after this right
however many they end up doing after
this before they decide to call it quits
kang could be a villain for a bunch of
different phases in the same way that
like this civil war event could have
been like an entire phase that stretched
all throughout these movies right like
imagine if you had civil war it's like a
whole phase and then you've got the
captain america movie tie into civil war
and you've got the iron man movie tie
into civil war right you could introduce
villains and you could you they could
have drastically expanded the marvel
cinematic universe they should have done
civil war later than they did because
the movie was more like civil
disagreements right captain america
three civil disagreement
right i mean those memes where it's like
iron man and captain america and it's
something ridiculous and then like the
third panel of civil war that's not far
off from being an accurate criticism of
of civil war it was a fun movie but it
should have been done later and there
should have been a lot more going on
there but having said that i mean i i
feel like kang could be that right he
could be this guy that just stretches on
for a series of movies all of which tie
into him because i'm not gonna lie i
kind of missed the days the first 10
years when we would have like thanos is
the main bad guy thanos is coming and
it's just like this little tidbit here
and this little thing there and that
little thing there and that little thing
there and when you go back and you watch
them it all just kind of leads into this
great big huge thing i understand things
change and i'm not adverse to things
changing what i would really like to see
though is that because kang represents
such a credible threat in in just in
general a guy who can manipulate the
time stream and control it i would like
to see them
treat him like more of a credible threat
and i would like to see him more than
just a guy who fights the cast of
ant-man in probably the quantum realm
and then he gets defeated and that's the
end of the movie because if that if that
really is just the life and times of
kang uh that's that's all it ever really
amounts to i feel it would be incredibly
lackluster so let me know what you guys
think am i overthinking this right you
guys think that kang is gonna have a
much bigger role in the mcu outside of
him just fighting scott lang and friends
in quantum mania or do you think he's
just going to be like just a simple
one-off villain right it's going to be
like yep he's part of the the new mcu
plan of them having some kind of a
villain over the course of like three or
four years and then he's going to die
and that's going to be it and it'll
basically be a great huge villain who
was billed as a credible threat had no
real lead up and then died in a single
film do you guys think that's what's
going to happen i really hope it's not
maybe loki season 2 will give us a
better idea of what's going on with king
but i really feel like this should be a
guy that gets that has a lot more
attention going to him than what he's
getting right now but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section and i will catch
you all later
peace